-[ Scratchy voice ]
Uh, he talks like this.
-Oscar the Grouch?
-Uh, no, uh...
[ Laughs ]
[ Stammers ]
-Yoda!
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes. Yes.
Uh, uh, uh...
He's an [Laughs] action --
action figure.
It's an action figure
from the '80s.
Uh, it was --
-He-Man.
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, they're doing something
very famous that's on TikTok.
-The squirrel dance?
-Uh...
-Flossing?
-Uh, it involves --
-The Griddy?
-...hitting each other with --
-Oh. Punching?
-Uh, no, but --
-Javelin?
-Uh, no.
It's a -- It's a, uh, burrito --
-Throw a burrito?
-No, but a burrito --
a burrito --
a burrito is wrapped aro--
-Chipotle?
-Uh, no -- yes.
But in --
A burrito [Stammers] the --
the base of a burrito.
-Taco?
-The -- No, but --
-Tortilla?
Tortilla?
-Yes.
And they're using the tortilla
as a big thing --
-Slap him with a tortilla?
-Yes!
Exactly!
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait, you gotta -- you gotta --
Reese, you have to see this.
-[ Laughing ]
-So silly.
I don't even understand.
This show airs in America,
by the way. Our show.
-[ Laughs ]
Uh, okay. We're waiting a second
while He-Man and Yoda...
-Let's get serious.
-Uh, I don't do a, uh, a good
Yoda impression.
Never have.
-Yeah, you d--
That wasn't very good.
-No.
[ Audience laughs ]
I just never did it 'cause it --
-You're really good
at a lot of stuff.
-There's other people that
do it so much better.
I just gave up on that one.
-It's just not your strength.
-No.
-It's okay.
-Oh, yeah. I do love Yoda.
Or, uh --
-R2-D2?
-Grogu, of course.
-Oh, Grogu, guys.
Have y'all seen "Mandalorian?"
-I mean...
-[ Gasps ]
-I mean, y'all...
-Y'all, I cried.
I cried so hard in the end
that my --
-I cried so hard, y'all.
-Y'all, I cried so hard
at "Mandalorian."
-I just thought he was so cute,
that little --
-[ Sighs ]
-Baby Yoda is so --
-I mean, I just want to put him
in my pocket.